a lot of people we've spoken to
are worried that their vote just doesn't
count that's why they're not even going
to vote
what would you say to them to those
people tell them to get off their
couches and get out here
just just the gesture the effort huh how
important is this particular election
this is one of this probably be one of
the most important elections ever
if i'm honest tell me why because it's a
lot at stake
it's a lot of state we need some changes
and um
this is a lot at stake all the way
around the board
we got to get out here let our voices be
heard so that's why we're here are you
confident that it's going to be a
genuine honest
election listen we're going to give it
the best effort we can and
and when the tallies come in we'll let
you know how we feel about that
that's phil right that's fair yeah has
georgia got
a problem with racial division wow you
gonna ask me that question
yeah what do you think i want to hear
from you because i'm not
from america i definitely think so i
definitely think so
absolutely can it be fixed i mean that's
why we are here
we're gonna do what we can for our
people that's why we're
you worried about here in the aftermath
of this election
i i am not what's up gangster
how you feeling right there i am not
we're peaceful people what about from
far right
militia that's on there we peace for
people
are you worried about the safety of them
i'm worried about uh voting to live
that's all we're worried about right now
tell them i said what's up in britain
though you say br bring question yeah
tell him i said what's up